cyril imagine un jour il ya un patron
qui t'a pas les 10 cyril bon tout va
bien mais il faut passer à autre chose
et vous êtes un as been tu fais quoi
non tu vois beaucoup de pierres ça une
fois un coup de boule d'accord mais
alors tu veux que tu dis la vérité
oui je pense qu'à 45 ans je te jure tu
me l'a dit oui je pose pas la question
par hasard non mais je dis franchement à
45 ans je pense que je ne serai plus
lente et franchement tu seras pas toi et
qui va le remplacer
on n'est pas fou on est plutôt fluide à
personne alors faire aussi bien sinon
mieux chaque fois que je vois civile je
me dis non dans trois quatre ans je
rentre dans l'appareil il y en a
beaucoup d'animateurs qui ont rêvé de
faire ça et s'il sent en doute le
premier à partir au top et à devenir
patron ou tu seras à mon avis un bon
patron y en a peut-être encore la
turquie